dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly jaw knife ahead a
decision tree is a great tool to help
making good decisions from a huge bunch
of data the classical example is when we
have a bunch of information about people
and would like to find out whether they
like computer games or not note that
this is a toy example for educational
purposes we can build the following tree
if the person's age in question is over
15 the person is less likely to like
computer games if the subject is under
15 and is a male he is quite likely to
like video games if she's female than
less likely note that the output of the
tree can be a decision like yes or no
but in our case we will assign positive
and negative scores instead you see in a
minute why that's beneficial but this
tree was just one possible way of
approaching the problem and admittedly
not a spectacular one a different
decision tree could be simply asking
whether this person uses a computer
daily or not individually these trees
are quite shallow and we call them weak
learners this term means that
individually they are quite inaccurate
but slightly better than random guessing
and now comes the cool part the concept
of tree boosting means that we take many
week learners and combine them into a
strong learner using the mentioned
scoring system instead of decisions also
makes this process easy and
straightforward to implement boosting is
similar to what we do with illnesses if
a doctor says that I have a rare
condition I will make sure and ask at
least a few more doctors to make a more
educated decision about my health the
cool thing is that the individual trees
don't have to be great if they give you
decisions that are just a bit better
than random guessing using a lot of them
will produce strong learning results if
we go back to the analogy with doctors
then if the individual doctors know just
enough not to kill the patient a
well-chosen committee will be able to
put together an accurate diagnosis for
the patient an even cooler adaptive
version of this technique brings in new
doctors to the committee according to
the deficiencies of the existing members
one other huge advantage of boosted
trees over neural networks is that we
actually see why and how the computer
arrives to a decision this is a
remarkably simple method that leads to
results of very respectable accuracy a
well-known software library called XG
boost has been responsible for winning a
staggering amount of machine learning
competitions in Cargill I'd like to take
a second and thank you fellow scholars
for your amazing support on patreon and
making two minute papers possible
creating these episodes is a lot of hard
work and your support has been
invaluable so far thank you so much we
used to have three categories for
supporters undergrad students get access
to a patreon only Activity Feed and get
to know well in advance the topics of
the new episodes PhD students who are
addicted to two minute papers get a
chance to see every episode up to 24
hours in advance talking about
committees in this episode full
professors form a committee to decide
the order of the next few episodes and
now we introduce a new category the
Nobel laureate supporters in this
category can literally become part of
two minute papers and will be listed in
the video description box in the
upcoming episodes plus all of the above
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time